AND THAT IS ONE OF THE
BEST IN THE BUSINESS WHEN HE
USED TO PLAY REGULARLY AND HE
COMES OFF THE COUCH
AFTER MISSING TWO YEARS OF
FOOTBALL
TO FILL IN FOR THE RAMS. AND
THEN IT WAS MORE THAN JUST A
PHILONY. WAS A DYNAMITE
CRUCIAL MEMBER
OF THIS.
SUPER BOWL RUNNING TEAM. NOW,
A SUPER BOWL CHAMPION, ERIC
WEDDLE HERE ON THE
RICH EYES, AND SHOW. HOW YOU
DOING, ERIC WEDDLE.
WEDDLE?
MY MAN,
MAN,
SUPER BOWL CHAMP, BRO.
CHAM. YEAH,
SUPER BOWL CHAMP. ALL RIGHT, I
DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO START
WITH YOU, BUT I'LL JUST START
WITH
WHEN DID YOU GET THE PHONE
CALL FROM THE RAMS, WHO CALLED
YOU WHO CALLED YOU FROM THE
RAMS,
ERIC RIGHT HERE
IN CALLED ME. I WAS IN, I WAS
IN A MEETING WITH THE
WAS A LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL
ABOUT TAKING OVER MAYBE IN
THE FUTURE,
THEIR FOOTBALL PROGRAM AND
I CAME OUT
AND HAD
MISSED CALL FROM HER, HE MAN
ATTACKED, AND I SAID,
HEY DUB. GIVE ME A CALL WHEN
YOU GET THIS. SO
MY FIRST INITIAL THOUGHT WAS
LIKE,
I'M NOT SURE WHAT HELP I CAN
DO
FOR THE, FOR THE PLAYOFF GAME
AGAINST THE,
AGAINST THE CARDINALS. I MEAN,
I HAVEN'T PLAYED AGAINST THEM
AND A COUPLE YEARS. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT SCOUTING I COULD DO
FOR THEM,
YOU KNOW, THIS WAS TUESDAY OF
GAME WEEK, AND I CALLED HIM
BACK
AND HE WAS LIKE, HEY,
WHAT YOU DOING? WE'RE JUST
CHOPPING IT UP AND THEN HE
JUST GOT STRAIGHT THROUGH.
HE'S LIKE, HEY, YOU'RE NOT
FAT AND OUT OF SHAPE.
MARIA. AND I SAID,
I SAID, OF COURSE, NOT, OF
COURSE NOT. BUT
WHAT
WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND SO
FROM THERE ON, HE
LAID DOWN, WHAT HIS,
WHAT THEY HAD THIS CRAZY
IDEA ABOUT ME, COMING BACK AND
HELPING THEM OUT. THEY WERE IN
DIRE NEED
AND
AFTER A FEW HOURS OF TALKING
TO OTHER COACHES AND PLAYERS
AND
THINKING IT THROUGH I SAID
SHOOT, WHY NOT MAN. THIS IS A
SECOND CHANCE OF A LIFETIME
AND
I'D REGRET.
I'D REGRET IT IF I DIDN'T
SEE IT THROUGH
FIVE WEEKS LATER
SUPER BOWL CHAMP.
IT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
SO WHO DID YOU CHOOSE? WHO DID
YOU TALK TO YOUR TALK TO
MCVEIGH? DID, WHO ELSE DID
YOU? WHO ELSE DID YOU SPEAK TO
WHEN YOU WERE CONSIDERING
AND OTHER PLAYERS? YEAH, YOU
TALK TO YOU
IMMEDIATELY WHEN I GOT OFF THE
PHONE WITH RAHIM. I CALLED
CHANEL AND
THAT'S WHAT MY WIFE'S NAME IS.
AMY, AND I AND I SAID,
HEY BABE, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY?
WHAT WOULD, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
IF I TOLD YOU MONDAY
NIGHT? IT COULD BE SUITING UP
FOR THE RAMS AND SHE SAID,
SHE STARTED LAUGHING. SHE'S
THAT NICE JOKE. WHAT'S REALLY
GOING ON?
I SAID, NO.
NO FOR REAL.
I JUST GOT
OFF THE PHONE WITH HER HIM',
SO I TALKED TO HER.
YOU KNOW, WHEN, AFTER GOING
THROUGH ALL THE STUFF, SHE
SAID, HEY, BABY, IF ANYONE CAN
DO IT, YOU CAN.
CAN. AND WHEN
YOU SAID
THAT I SAID, YOU KNOW WHAT,
YOU'RE RIGHT. LIKE I SAID, I
WAS ON THE FENCE
IS REALLY LIKE
PHYSICALLY.
I HAVEN'T DONE. YOU KNOW, I
WORK OUT, BUT I WORK OUT JUST
TO MAKE MY BODY FEEL BETTER
AND TO,
YOU KNOW, TO STAY IN SHAPE.
AND, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU, WHEN
YOU PLAY FOR, AS LONG AS I
HAVE, IT JUST BECOMES A
PART OF YOU, YOU KNOW, WORKING
OUT AND TRYING TO STAY HEALTHY
AND
DO THOSE THINGS. AND AND
THAT WAS JUST LIKE, I DON'T
KNOW, YOU KNOW AND WHAT SHE
SAID THAT I WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW
WHAT, YOU'RE RIGHT LIKE I LOOK
AT MYSELF AS ONE OF THE MOST
MENTALLY TOUGH
AS GUYS IN THE
THIS WORLD. AND
IF ANYONE CAN DO IT, I COULD
DO THEN, I CIRCLE BACK WITH A
COUPLE OF THE COACHES. THEN I
LAST TALKED TO SEAN ABOUT
THREE, PROBABLY THREE HOURS
LATER AFTER THE INITIAL CALL,
YOU KNOW, WHEN WHERE HE CALLED
AROUND 3:30
PRICE CIRCLE, BACK TO THE
CHAMPS AROUND 7:00
AND
YOU KNOW, HE WAS ALL ON BOARD
WITH IT AND AND THEN
YOU KNOW, BY ABOUT 9:30
DECIDED TO ROLL.
I GOT UP THERE ABOUT 1 A.M.
AND WAS IN THE BUILDING BY
5:30 GETTING TO WORK.
UNBELIEVABLE. YOU CANNOT MAKE
IT UP ERIC WEDDLE. YOU
CANNOT MAKE UP WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE YOU ALSO PLAYED
EXPERTLY, YOU, LIKE YOU, YOU
PLAY.
I MEAN, YOU, YOU
HOW MANY DID YOU PLAY
60 SNAPS
AGAINST THE NINERS,
DID YOU? AND THE CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME? IS THAT? DID YOU WORK
YOUR WAY UP TO LIKE
60 DEFENSIVE SNAPS ERIC?
YEAH. YEAH, I MEAN,
FIRST
WEEK. I PLAYED 19 RIGHT
AGAINST THE CARDINALS. AND
LUCKILY WE WERE BLOWING THEM
OUT, RIGHT?
THE PLANE, THE SECOND HALF
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY,
I ACTUALLY
AGGRAVATED MY HAMMY AND
GROWING IN THAT GAME. NO.
SO IT WOULD HAVE BEEN,
I WOULD HAVE WENT BACK IN
THERE, BUT I PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE TORE EVERYTHING AND THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE END OF
THIS SPECIAL RUN.
BUT THANKFULLY, WE DIDN'T. AND
THEN THE NEXT WEEK.
I PLAYED 61 SNACKS
AGAINST TAMPA
AND THEN
PLACE HE'S PLAYED
EVERYTHING PUT
HE STARTED AND PLAYED
EVERYTHING, THE NFC
CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE SUPER
BOWL. WHAT DID BRODY SAY TO
YOU? WHEN HE SAW YOU IN THAT
GAME?
DID HE SAY SOMETHING TO YOU,
ERIC?
YEAH, HE WAS, YOU KNOW, I JUST
WANTED
TO, YOU KNOW, SHOW MY RESPECT
TO HIM
AFTER THE GAME
AND AND LET HIM KNOW HOW MUCH
I ADMIRE HIM AND LOOK UP TO
HIM. AND HE WAS JUST LIKE,
DUDE, YOU GOT TO BE SORE. AS
YOU KNOW, WHAT IS HE?
WHAT,
WE JUST TALKED BACK AND FORTH
A LITTLE BIT AND
JUST WHAT A
YOU KNOW,
HE'S THE GOAT AND
JUST WANTED TO LET HIM KNOW.
HE INSPIRED ME FROM AFAR.
WELL, MAYBE YOU MIGHT INSPIRE
HIM TO COME BACK. ERIC.
I DON'T KNOW,
YOU KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT. I MEAN,
IT'S JUST CRAZY. A LOT OF
THINGS THAT DO A LINE, RIGHT?
BOTH SAFETIES HAVE TO GO DOWN,
THEY HAD NO DEPTH BEHIND THAT.
AND
YOU KNOW, THEY KNEW ME THEY
KNEW THAT I WOULD BE IN
SOMEWHAT GOOD ENOUGH SHAPE TO
EVEN TRY IT,
RIGHT? I COULD HAVE FALL.
OUT OF MY FACE, THE TWO
PRACTICES BEFORE MONDAY NIGHT,
BUT THAT WASN'T GOING TO
I MEAN, I'M
I'M I CAN GO OUT THERE AND
GIVE THEM A FEW SNAPS,
BUT THE TO BUILD AND
TO MAKE IT WHAT IT WAS
TO START IN THE SUPER BOWL
AND TO HAVE AN IMPACT THAT
I DID AND TO HELP THESE GUYS.
WAS SOMETHING THAT I'LL
CHERISH FOR THE REST OF MY
LIFE AND
HOPE PEOPLE SEE
THAT WHEN AN OPPORTUNITY COMES
ACROSS.
HOPEFULLY YOU'RE READY FOR IT
AND
YOU'RE AND YOU'RE READY,
RIGHT? BECAUSE
AN OPPORTUNITY OF A LIFETIME
CAME TO ME AND EVEN THOUGH I
WASN'T 100%
READY, I TOOK
THE CHANCE AND LOOK WHAT
HAPPENED. I'M A SUPER BOWL
CHAMP NOW. ERIC.
WHY DON'T HEAR ON THE RICH
EYES AND SHOW
NINE YEARS WITH SAN DIEGO
AND THE CHARGERS? AND THEN
THREE WITH BALTIMORE AND THEN
YOUR LAST ONE WITH THE RAMS,
YOU RETIRE, YOU KNOW, WE
CHATTED AFTER YOU RETIRED AND
NOW HERE YOU ARE CHAMPION WITH
THE RAMS AFTER THAT STORY,
YOU JUST TOLD
WHAT WAS
SUPER SUNDAY LIKE FOR YOU WAS
IT WHAT YOU DREAMT ABOUT,
ABOUT ERIC? IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
IT WAS REALLY
FLOWS, THE UPS AND DOWNS THE
ADVERSITY,
EVERYTHING THAT
YOU FEEL FOOTBALL GAME.
IS AN AND WAS
FROM A PLAYER'S STANDPOINT.
YOU NEVER REALLY REALIZE ALL
THE ALL THE OTHER.
I WOULDN'T SAY
ABS BUT JUST AS A PLAYER LIKE
THE TIMEOUTS WERE SO LONG
THE HALFTIME SHOW LIKE
THE ROCK GETTING UP THERE AND
DOING THE THING. THAT'S LIKE,
ARE WE
THE SHOW OR THERE ANYTHING
ELSE TO SHOW?
SHOW?
IT WAS,
IT WAS JUST LIKE KIND OF LIKE
HEY,
WE HAD 40 MINUTES BEFORE
WE LET THE FEEL LIKE WHY NOT
DO ALL THIS STUFF DURING THAT
TIME INSTEAD OF HAVING A
40 MINUTE COUNTDOWN, THEN
HAVE ALL THESE OTHER THINGS
GOING ON, THEN THE ROD GETS
OUT THERE
WHEN ZEROS ON THE CONGRESS
WASN'T GOT AND THEN HE'S GOING
FOR ANOTHER
5 MINUTES. IT'S LIKE
HOLY SMOKES.
YOU KNOW, I KNOW, I KNOW IT'S
A SPECTACLE FOR THE
WORLD AND THIS AND THAT. YEAH.
WHEN THE GAME WAS BEING
PLAYED WHEN WE WERE
WEREN'T STAYING AROUND ON
TIMEOUTS. EVERYTHING ELSE. IT
WAS INCREDIBLE IN AND THEN
BEING A PART OF THE LAST PLAY
AND WATCHING IT UNFOLD.
RIGHT BEFORE MY OWN EYES AND
LIVE ACTION WAS,
OR SOMETHING THAT I CAN
LITERALLY BE IN THAT MOMENT
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE. WELL
BUT GO AHEAD. NOW, BEFORE WE
GET TO THAT, THOUGH. I DO WANT
TO, I'M SORRY. I DON'T JUST
HOP IN HERE. WHEN DID YOU
TEAR YOUR PACK THOUGH? WHEN
DID THAT
HAPPEN? ERIC? IN YOUR
HEAD? IT WAS IN THE FIRST
QUARTER.
IT.
YOU KNOW, I REWATCHED THE PLAY
LAST NIGHT WHEN I GOT THE GAME
FILM. AND,
AND I FIRST INITIALLY THOUGHT,
LIKE I THOUGHT JOE MIXON,
JUST KICKED ME OR OR,
OR STEPPED ON ME,
BECAUSE IT WAS LIKE,
I JUST DIDN'T KNOW. I'M LIKE,
HOW IN THE WORLD
IS MY SHOULDER PECK HURTING
SO BAD. SO THEN I RE-WATCHED
IT IS ACTUALLY MY TEAMMATE
WAS RUNNING BEHIND HIM AND HE
KICKED MY ARM AS I WAS
TACKLING THEM. SO IT WAS
JUST
AND IT
WENT THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION,
WHICH IS JUST SO
CRAZY AND
UNFORTUNATE. YOU KNOW, WHAT
ARE THE ODDS OF THAT
HAPPENING? BUT YEAH,
I JUST,
I WAS IN A LOT OF PAIN BUT I'M
LIKE, THIS IS A SUPER BOWL
MAN. I CAN RUN,
I CAN STILL TALK AND
COMMUNICATE.
YEAH, IS IT GONNA HURT EVERY
SECOND? YEAH, BUT I GOT
50 YEARS TO REHAB THIS
THING AND GO GET
SURGERY AND DO WHAT I NEED TO
DO. BUT AS LONG AS I WASN'T
A LIABILITY OUT THERE,
I WASN'T GOING TO BE I WASN'T
GOING TO COME OUT THAT FIELD
NOT IN THAT
MOMENT.
WHEN I DREAMT OF THIS
SITUATION, I WAS LIKE, I'M NOT
GOING OUT LIKE THIS. SO YOU
ARE YOU JUST BETTER CLUTCH UP?
GET YOUR MIND RIGHT AND TOUGH
IT UP. GET YOUR AREN'T
YOU'RE WRONG. YOU'RE ON YOUR
RIGHT SIDE, RIGHT? BECAUSE
WE'RE SEEING YOU
TACKLE JAMAR CHASE WITH ONE
LEFT ARM RIGHT HERE
ON OUR SCREEN,
YOU KNOW, LIKE, THAT'S SO
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE. ONE LEFT
ARM TACKLER, THE REST OF THE
DAY. THEN PRETTY MUCH
RIGHT. IS THAT IT? YEAH. YEAH.
I MEAN JUST, YOU KNOW,
I'VE STOOD JUST THROWING THE
WHOLE BODY IN THERE, WHATEVER
IT TOOK,
YOU KNOW, A FEW TIMES.
THEY'RE JUST THROUGH MY BODY
IN THERE. AND,
YOU KNOW, HOPEFULLY WHEN I
LOOKED UP THAT THE GUY WAS
TACKLED.
SO
IN THAT MOMENT, YOU'RE JUST
WHATEVER AND THEN SOMETIMES
YOU JUST HAD TO, YOU HAVE TO
THROW YOUR RIGHT ARM IN THERE
AND
AND JUST GET THROUGH IT. THE
PAIN, THE PAIN WAS,
YOU GOT USED TO IT AFTER A
WHILE
AND
YOU KNOW, IT'S BIGGER THAN
THAT. IT'S BIGGER MYSELF. THIS
THIS WAS ABOUT THE MOMENT,
RIGHT? THE MOMENT
OF WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
AND ARE YOU
GOING TO? ARE YOU GOING TO
CLUTCH UP MIND OVER MATTER AND
HELP YOUR TEAM
WIN?
BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY, OR
ARE YOU, OR ARE YOU NOT? AND
FOR ME?
IT WAS IT WASN'T EVEN A
QUESTION
AS LIKE, HEY.
HEY, LET'S GO DO THIS.
LET'S GET THIS WIN AND BE
IMMORTALIZED IN THE HISTORY
BOOKS FOR THE REST OF OUR
LIVES.
FEW MORE MINUTES LEFT HERE
WITH SUPER BOWL CHAMPION.
ERIC WEDDLE OF THE LOS ANGELES
RAMS,
THE TUESDAY AFTER SUPER BOWL
FIFTY SIX HERE ON THE RICHES
AND SHOW, LET'S GET TO THE
LAST
DEFENSIVE SNAP FOR YOU
IN THE GAME AND IN YOUR
CAREER,
WALK ME THROUGH
FOURTH AND SHORT
WITH TIME, WINDING DOWN
IN SUPER BOWL.
FIFTY SIX. ERIC WALK ME
THROUGH THAT ONE. YES,
SO WE'RE COMING OUT. WE HAVE
A
PLAY MAN-TO-MAN. I WAS ON THEM
OR THROUGH. TYLER BOYD. AND
WE HAVE LOW WHOLE HELP. SO THE
WAY WE PLAY THAT,
YOU KNOW, ANY TYPE OF
SHALLOWER IN CUT,
YOU KNOW, T RAP WAS INSIDE
OF ME. SO HE'LL
OVER TAKE THAT AND THEN I
FLASH THE SECOND WINDOW. AND
AS THEY CAME OUT IN THE
FORMATION,
WE KNEW WHOSE A RUNNING BACK
WAS MIXING WASN'T IN THERE. SO
THEY AIN'T RUNNING THE BALL,
ESPECIALLY
GETTING STUFF DONE
CERTAIN ONES
AND THEN YOU HEAR THE CHECKS.
YOU HEAR ALL THE THINGS YOU
STUDIED THROUGHOUT THE WEEK
AND YOU FEEL LIKE IT'S GOING
TO BE PASSED.
AND YOU KNOW,
DO A DETOX A LOT ABOUT THAT
AFTER THE GAME, WHERE HE GOT
SUCH A GREAT JUMP OFF THE BALL
NEW AND KNOWING THAT
IT WAS PASSED AND HE HAD A, HE
HAD HIS BEST
PASTORIS MOVE READY
AND FOR US ON THE
BACKEND, I MEAN IT WAS WE HAD
THAT LOCKED DOWN THE ROCK
COMBINATION IN THE CONCEPT WAS
THERE WASN'T ANYWHERE TO THROW
THE BALL. ANYWAYS,
SO WHETHER IT WAS A D GOING TO
GET TO HIM OR SOMEONE ELSE,
SEE HE WAS GONNA HAVE TO
JOE'S GONNA HAVE TO MAKE
SOMETHING HAPPEN BECAUSE SO
THE FIRST READ THE SECOND
READING, THE THIRD READ
WEREN'T THERE AND WE HAD IT
ALL GLOVED UP.
FROM THE OUTSIDE, BUT NUMBER
ONE,
AND AT THAT POINT HE WAS
GETTING HIT BY A D AND THEN IT
WAS LIKE, OH MY GOSH,
YOU'RE JUST YOU'RE JUST
THINKING YOURSELF. THIS IS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT'S HAPPENING
THE BALL FLOP
WALLS AND, YOU KNOW, THROWS IT
UP IN THE AIR. JUST TRYING TO
MAKE
THEM HAPPEN, ANY HIT THE
GROUND. AND IN THAT MOMENT,
YOU KNOW,
YOUR SUPER BOWL CHAMP, THERE'S
ONE TIMEOUT, THEY HAVE NOTHING
LEFT. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
KNEE
AND THE ENERGY, THE
PASSION, THE
THE JUST TO
CELEBRATE WITH YOUR TEAMMATE
IS LIKE, NOTHING. YOU'LL EVER
BE A PART OF THE REST OF YOUR
LIFE. THAT THAT MOMENT
IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU DREAM OF AND TO BE
ABLE TO LIVE IT AND TO
BE ABLE TO BE IN MY SITUATION
FIVE WEEKS AGO TO. NOW, WHEN I
THOUGHT THAT DREAM WAS OVER.
I'M JUST SUPER, SUPER
HUMBLED AND
FORTUNATE AND BLESSED TO BE
HAVE THAT MOMENT
IN MY LIFE. FOR THE FIRST OF
THE HISTORY BOOKS. I WAS A
PART OF THAT PLAY TO WIN THE
SUPER BOWL,
DAMN STRAIGHT. YOU WERE
ERIC WEDDLE. HOW
HIS ERRAND. UM,
I MEAN LIKE LIKE LIKE WHAT I
I MEAN, I KNOW, RIGHT? I MEAN
PEOPLE BEEP.
KIND OF TAKE FOR GRANTED WHAT
HE IS AND WHAT HE'S ALL ABOUT,
RIGHT? AND IT'S
JUST IT'S HARD TO FATHOM
IF HE EVER
EVER GOT JUST
SINGLE BLOCKS,
THE MAJORITY OF A GAME. WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN? I MEAN LITERALLY
HE GETS THE
HE GETS THE OFFENSIVE LINE
ROTATION TO HIM EVERY TIME
LIKE LITERALLY. AND WHEN HE
DOESN'T,
IT'S A SACK, OR IF THE TFL OR
IT'S A IT'S A HIT ON THE
QB. I MEAN, THAT'S HOW GREAT
HE IS AND
I PLAY WITH A LOT OF GREAT
PLAYERS.
HE'S BY FAR THE BEST PLAYER
I'VE EVER PLAYED WITH
AT ANY POSITION
AND
IT'S, HE JUST DOES SO MUCH FOR
OUR TEAM, OUR DEFENSE.
THE SUCCESS OTHER GUYS HAVE
BECAUSE OF HIM
AND THE ATTENTION THAT HE GETS
GOES,
UNSAID
BUT I MEAN, JEEZ,
THE
INDIVIDUAL
ACCOLADES
ARE SECOND TO NONE.
HE'S AN EVEN BETTER TEAMMATE.
BETTER BETTER, MAN.
HE'S ONE OF ONE OF ONE WHEN
I SAY 101. THERE IS NO OTHER
AD.
THERE WILL NEVER BE ANOTHER AD
AND WE JUST GOT TO APPRECIATE
HIS GREENER. WELL, I MEAN
AND
WHILE WE'RE ON THE SUBJECT,
YOUR HARD TO FATHOM,
IT'S HARD TO FATHOM THAT HE'D
WALK AWAY AT AGE 30
AT THE TOP OF HIS GAME
LIKE THIS. YOU KNOW, WHAT A
PLAYER WHO'S THINKING OF
RETIRING OR KNOWS. IT'S TIME
TO RETIRE.
LOOK.
IT'S LIKE YOU USED TO BE ONE
AND YOU ARE NOW ONE AGAIN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK? DO YOU
THINK THAT HE'S
THIS IS REALLY SOMETHING HE'S
THINKING ABOUT OR COULD
HAPPEN.
ERIC WILL BE COMING.
BECOME. I JUST KNOW WHEN
IT GETS TO THE POINT
WHERE
YOU CAN'T DO WHAT YOU NORMALLY
DO
PHYSICALLY,
IT BECOMES DRAINING,
RIGHT? IT MENTALLY
YOU HAVE TO DO SO MUCH TO KEEP
YOURSELF
YOURSELF AT THE LEVEL.
YOU
EXPECT OF YOURSELF,
RIGHT? AND WHEN YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO PRACTICE EVERY DAY,
WHEN YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO LIFT
EVERY DAY AND DO WHAT YOU LOVE
TO DO,
BECAUSE YOUR BODY IS JUST
HURTING OR YOUR BODY'S
BREAKING DOWN. IT TAKES A TOLL
ON YOU. SO I DON'T KNOW
HOW
IF HE, THAT'S HOW IT WAS FOR
ME, AND I JUST FELT
THAT I MENTALLY COULDN'T KEEP
UP WITH IT. IT'S THE SAME
THING THAT TOM TALKED ABOUT
WHEN HE RETIRED IF YOU'RE NOT
100%
COMMITTED
MENTALLY TO DOING EVERYTHING
THAT THIS JOB ENTAILS.
THEN YOU JUST CAN'T DO IT.
HE JUST
CAN'T DO IT. SO YOU
NEEDED. YOU JUST GOT TO GO.
YOU GOT TO STEP AWAY
AND FOR HIM. I DON'T KNOW.
THAT THAT WILL BE FOR HIM TO
DECIDE I THINK
GOOD GETTING AWAY FROM THE
GAME
GETTING AWAY
LETTING YOUR BODY
FULLY RECOVER AND
AND
YOU KNOW, DO I THINK HE WILL?
I DON'T THINK SO.
BUT
YOU UNDERSTAND IT. IF SO AS A
PLAYER II, TOTALLY GET IT. IF
HE'S READY. AND IF
HIS MIND IS NOT IN IT, AND
HE'S TIRED OF
EVERYTHING THAT IT IS, THAT IT
IMPLIES OF BEING
GREAT.
I TOTALLY GET IT. SO
WE SHALL SEE.
I PROBABLY
BE THE LAST ONE TO FIGURE IT
OUT, BUT
HOPEFULLY
MORE GREAT. GREAT DAYS AHEAD
OF THEM. BUT IF IT IS, I MEAN
HE'S ONE OF THE ALL-TIME
GREATS AND AND
EVERYONE SHOULD APPLAUD WHAT
HE'S DONE SO FAR,
AND I KNOW I DO. AND THE
COUPLE MINUTES I HAVE LEFT
WITH YOU, ERIC WEDDLE. I JUST
WANT TO KNOW WHAT IT WAS LIKE
FOR SOME OF THESE HUGS, THESE
SUPER BOWL
POST SUPER BOWL. WINNING HOGS.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE WITH RAHEEM
MORRIS? THE DEFENSIVE
COORDINATOR WHO CALLED YOU ON
THAT DAY.
WHAT DO YOU?
SAY, TO THIS GUY
FROM THE
JOURNEY IS COMPLETE. AND THE
ULTIMATE WAY LIKE THAT. WHAT
DO YOU SAY? WHAT WAS THAT?
LIKE
IT WAS, YOU KNOW, WE JUST
YOU KNOW, HE COACHED ME AT THE
SENIOR BOWL
15 YEARS AGO,
TEN YEARS AGO WHENEVER IT WAS.
AND WE ALWAYS TALKED ABOUT
HAVING A CHANCE TO BE
ON THE SAME SIDE, RIGHT?
WHETHER HE COACHED ME.
AT SOME POINT IN OUR CAREERS
AND TO HAVE IT COME FULL
CIRCLE IN THIS MOMENT.
IS JUST SO SPECIAL FOR HIM AND
I AND HE'S GOING TO
BE A HEAD COACH ONE DAY AND
HOPEFULLY WHEN SUPER BOWL
HE IS JUST HAS THAT IT
FACTOR.
HE KNOWS HOW TO RELATE TO THE
PLAYERS. WHO KNOWS HOW TO
CONNECT
TO US.
IT'S EVEN
KILL DEMEANOR IS SO MUCH LIKE
ME AS A PLAYER. SO WE JUST
CONNECT ON ANOTHER LEVEL
AND BEING ABLE TO TALK
BALL, TALK SHOP.
I'M JUST SO HAPPY FOR HIM. I'M
GRATEFUL THAT HE
EVEN THOUGHT
OF THE IDEA
TO BRING ME BACK HIM AND
KOJI IS JUST SOME, I'M FOREVER
INDEBTED TO HIM, RIGHT?
BECAUSE HE GAVE ME A CHANCE TO
LIVE A SECOND LIFE AS A KID.
WHEN NO ONE GETS HIS CHANCE,
RIGHT?
YOU'RE RETIRED FOR TWO YEARS.
YOU DON'T GET A CHANCE LIKE
THIS
AND
I OWE THAT I OWE THE SUPER
BOWL RING FOR HIM
FOR GIVING ME THIS CHANCE TO
HAVE A ROLE ON THIS TEAM AND
AND, AND TAKING IT AND RUN
WITH IT. SO,
WE'LL BE FOREVER CONNECTED.
THAT'S WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
WELL, WE'RE FOREVER CONNECTED
IN THIS LIFE AS SUPER BOWL
CHANCE AND DOING SOMETHING
THAT NOBODY IS DONE
AND PROBABLY WILL NEVER DO
AGAIN OF DOING WHAT WE DID.
COME AT HER.
AND MAKING THE MAKING A
SPLASH.
WHAT WAS YOUR HUG WITH
STAFFORD? LIKE, YOU KNOW,
ANOTHER GUY
LONGTIME VETERAN IN THE
LEAGUE. WHO'S NOW GOT THAT
RING? LIKE YOU ERIC
WHAT ABOUT THAT ONE?
YEAH, MAN, YOU KNOW, WE JUST
IT WAS JUST A MOMENT, YOU
KNOW, WE WANTED THIS SO MUCH
FOR EACH OTHER.
YOU KNOW, I WASN'T A PART OF
THIS SEASON, THE WHOLE TEAM.
THE, YOU KNOW, THE WHOLE
SEASON OBVIOUSLY,
BUT I'D WATCHED EVERY GAME
I WATCH THE REPLAY. SO, I FELT
EMOTIONALLY. I ATTACHED TO
THEM
WHY?
WATCHING HIS CAREER FROM AFAR
AND THEN BEING A TEAMMATE FOR
THE LAST FIVE WEEKS,
AND JUST GROWING APPRECIATION
OF HOW HARD HE WORKS AND
IN THE COMMAND, AND THE
OWNERSHIP AND
JUST HE IS, HE IS A
QUARTERBACK
THROUGH AND THROUGH AND WHAT
YOU WANT, RIGHT?
HOW HE OWNS IT. HOW HE
HOW HE STANDS ON THE TABLE FOR
WHAT HE WANTS TO DO, WHAT HE
DOES AND HOW HE CHALLENGES
HIS
COACHES, HOW HE CHALLENGES HIS
PLAYERS AND EXPECTS GREATNESS.
AND IT WAS JUST IN THAT
MOMENT. WE WERE JUST
YOU KNOW, SAYING HOW MUCH
OF THIS MOMENT WE DID FOR EACH
OTHER, RIGHT? HOW HE
WANTED TO DO IT FOR
WHEN YOU WANT TO DO IT, FOR
AD, WANTED TO DO IT FOR MYSELF
AND VICE VERSA. AND THAT WAS
WHAT WAS SO SPECIAL ABOUT THIS
GROUP OF MEN, MAN. WE WANTED
TO DO IT FOR EACH OTHER. IT
WASN'T SO MUCH ABOUT DOING
IT FOR MYSELF. IT WAS ABOUT
HAVING THIS CHANCE TO DO IT
FOR FOR THE GUYS THAT HAVE
BEEN IN THE LEAGUE FOR SO LONG
AND DONE SO MUCH,
BUT NOW WE'RE HERE AND WE CAN
SIT HERE AND SAY
WE'RE SUPER BOWL CHANCE,
BECAUSE WE DID IT FOR EACH
OTHER.
NOT FOR OURSELVES.
AND THEN LASTLY, WITH YOUR
WIFE WHO'S BEEN WITH YOU, THIS
ENTIRE JOURNEY.
WHAT WAS THAT HUG? LIKE,
ERIC? WHAT WAS THAT MOMENT?
LIKE IF YOU DON'T MIND ME
ASKING? YEAH,
IT WAS, IT WAS
EMOTIONAL. IT WAS
YOU KNOW, I WOULDN'T BE HERE
WITHOUT HER
OVER THE COURSE,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE BEEN MARRIED
COMING UP ON 17 YEARS.
WE GOT MARRIED IN COLLEGE.
SHE'S BEEN IN THERE.
BEEN THROUGH THE GRIND AND,
AND ONLY THE WIVES,
NO OF THE NFL. WHAT IT, WHAT
IT'S LIKE,
NOT HAVING THEIR HUSBANDS HOME
FOR SIX, SEVEN MONTHS AT A
TIME
AND BEING ABLE TO SUPPORT.
AND ENCOURAGE
AND BE THAT PERSON THAT IS
ALWAYS THERE FOR YOU
ON THE
UPS AND DOWNS.
SHE IS ONE OF A KIND OF SHE
WAS. THE ROCK
IS THE ROCK OF
FAMILY IN THE HELD US
TOGETHER.
AND
IN THAT MOMENT. I MEAN WE'RE
STILL IN AWE. WE'RE STILL
IN SHOCK THAT THIS ACTUALLY
HAPPENED
AND FOR HER TO SUPPORT ME
AND REALLY
WHEN SHE SAID ANYBODY, NOBODY
COULD DO IT, BUT BUT ME,
I MEAN, SHE WAS THE ONE THAT
GAVE ME THE CONFIDENCE TO GO
TRY THIS.
SHE REALLY WAS AND SHE'S
BEEN THERE.
AND I JUST HOPE THAT
OVER THE NEXT 50, ODD YEARS
THAT I'M, YOU KNOW, I THINK
I'M GOING TO LIVE TO 100. SO
I'M GOING TO SAY,
67 OUT. OF COURSE
I DON'T,
BOY THAT. I KEEP THAT I CAN
GIVE HER THE ATTENTION
AND
SERVE AND SACRIFICE
WITH HER AND THE KIDS AS MUCH
AS SHE DID FOR ME BECAUSE
IT WAS SECOND IN THEM.
ERIC WEDDLE. YOU HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN ONE OF MY FAVORITES WHEN
I HEARD YOU WERE COMING
ON OVER TIME WITH THE RAMS.
I'M LIKE, YOU'VE GOT TO BE
KIDDING ME
AND NOW THAT THAT
WHOLE SENSE OF YOU GOT TO BE
KIDDING. ME
IS OFF THE CHARTS,
YOUR SUPER BOWL
CHAMPION,
WHAT AN UNBELIEVABLE
ENDING,
FAIRY TALE THAT NOBODY SAW
COMMON.
THANKS FOR THE TIME AND
SHARON. YOU'RE REALLY ONE OF
MY FAVES. CONGRATS.
YOU DESERVE IT.
RICH. RICH. LOVE YOU, BRO.
PREFECT CATCHER AND
SUPER BOWL CHANCE.
I'M IN THE CLUB. FINALLY
YOU ARE INTEGRATING YOUR IN
THE CLOCK.
YOU'RE IN THE CLUB. YES,
INDEED. WE HAVE, WE HAVE A
CLUB RIGHT HERE. AS A MATTER
OF FACT THAT YOU'RE ALLOWED
INTO ANY TIME ANY TIME,
ERIC, WEDDLE. ENJOY THE
PARADE. HAVE A GOOD TIME.
I WILL TAKE CARE OF YOURSELF,
BROTHER. YOU BET YOU'D BE
WELL, THE ONE AND ONLY.
ERIC WEDDLE, SO AWESOME.
SUPER BOWL CHAMPION.
WHAT A STORY
THAT ASK THE ULTIMATE RISE AND
SHINE.
BROUGHT TO YOU BY
COURTYARD BY MARRIOTT
AS THE OFFICIAL HOTEL OF THE
NFL FOR 11 YEARS
AND COUNTING COURTYARD. BY
MARRIOTT IS
OUT TO FEEL YOUR LOVE OF THE
GAME ALL SEASON LONG
WHEN YOU'RE ON THE ROAD. NO
REASON TO MISS OUT ON WATCHING
THE GAME. YOU CAN MEET US AT
THE BISTRO BAR TO CHEER ON
YOUR FAVORITE TEAM WITH GOOD
FOOD AND GOOD COMPANY. IF
YOU'RE TRAVELING TO AN
OUT-OF-TOWN GAME WITH OVER.
1,000 HOTELS ACROSS THE
U.S. COURTYARDS, GOT THE
PERFECT PLACE
FOR YOU TO STAY NEAR THE
STADIUM. AND IF YOU'RE A
MARRIED, BON VOYAGE MEMBER
DISCOVER EVEN MORE WAYS TO
EARN AND REDEEM POINTS WITH
ACCESS TO EXCLUSIVE
NFL EXPERIENCES AT COURTYARD
BY MARRIOTT.
PASSION MOVES US FORWARD.
WHERE WILL YOURS TAKE